Continuing in Al-Wajeez fi Sunnah wal
Kitab al-Aziz fi Kitab al-Siyam, the
book of fasting,
in the chapter regarding the
pillars of fasting.
And
we are discussing the sub-chapter
of the things that break a person's
fast, the things that will nullify a
person's fast.
And
we've mentioned
six of them.
Let's see if we can name them.
The first and second,
eating and drinking purposely. Number
three,
inducing yourself to vomit. Number four
and five,
menstruation and postpartum
bleeding. And number six,
al-jima, which is
intercourse.
And we were discussing the evidence for
the sixth.
And that evidence is the narration, one
of the evidences. The book is named
Al-Wajeez, the summary.
Right?
The summary. It's an abridged,
summarized
book. It's not going to mention every
single evidence.
It is a book that is geared towards
mentioning the most prominent evidence
in that particular issue.
And so, he chooses, the author chooses,
the narration of Abu Hurairah, which is
in Bukhari and Muslim and Sunan
al-Tirmidhi and Sunan Abi Dawud and Ibn
Majah and Muwatta Malik,
on the authority of Abu Hurairah,
who narrates
that
[Silence]
He says,
Abu Hurairah narrates, "Once while we
were sitting in the company of the
Prophet,
a man
approached
and he said, 'Oh messenger of Allah, I
am done. I'm finished.'"
And so he asked, "What is the matter?"
The man responded, "I
have fell into intercourse with my
wife while I was fasting."
Now, we mentioned before, the Prophet
didn't need to increase the man's
anxiety.
The man already came saying, "I'm done."
I'm done. And in the narration of
Muwatta Malik, "I'm burned."
I've I'm burned. Right?
Meaning I'm finished.
And so the man doesn't need to be told
this is a major sin, what you did was
wrong. Right? He doesn't need judgment.
He needs recourse at this point.
We also learn from this something very
important.
And that is fear.
Unnecessary anxiety
and
hopelessness after a sin has been
committed
is not beneficial.
It is beneficial in that fear keeps us
away from haram.
And fear drives us to repent.
But anything that does not serve a
purpose beyond
helping us to abstain from haram and
driving us to repentance will breed
hopelessness.
Will breed unnecessary anxiety.
Will breed negativity associated
with Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala and his
message.
And so, a shaytan uses this.
He uses this.
He is Al-Waswas
Al-Khannas.
What is Al-Waswas?
He whispers.
What is Al-Khannas?
He retreats.
What does that mean?
He whispers, whispers, whispers, and
then when you do what he says, he leaves
you.
That's you, buddy. You deal with that. I
didn't tell you to do that. Look what
you've done.
Or when a person seeks refuge in Allah,
he retreats.
Or he whispers and then retreats and
leaves a person hanging.
But he also whispers after the sin to
breed hopelessness.
To breed unnecessary undue anxiety.
Allah
describes those that disbelieve in Allah
and the last day.
Those who are hopeless of Allah's mercy
are those who disbelieve in Allah and
the last day. Not the believer. Believer
is never hopeless. As a matter of fact,
a human being,
as long as he has air in his lungs, as
long as his
soul is not being
dragged out of his body,
he still has hope.
Right? And what is the Quran?
It's a book of hope. The whole thing.
Even the verses of punishment, even the
verses of wa'id,
it's a book of hope. Because the fact
that you're listening to these verses
that scare you,
this is hope. There's still hope.
And so the Quran is a book of hope. It
came to people in a time of darkness.
A time of deep darkness and confusion.
And it pierced that darkness with hope.
Right?
And so, a shaytan whispers.
When a person has already committed a
sin,
that excessive anxiety that comes even
after a person has repented, a lot of
this is all is often driven by a
shaytan.
And likewise,
hopefulness
while committing a sin is also from a
shaytan.
See, we are supposed to have fear
before committing a sin. Hope after
committing a sin. A shaytan will give us
hope while committing a sin and give us
fear after.
And so,
he said,
"Do you have a slave that you could free
or emancipate?" He said, "No."
He said, "Are you able to fast two
consecutive months?"
He said, "No."
He said, "Then do you have the ability
to feed 60 poor people?"
He said, "No."
So,
this guy is not bringing
many options here.
He's got this big problem and he's got
no way to
address any of the
solutions that the Prophet
has laid before him. Has laid before
him. And we take from this narration
order.
Meaning that these are to be done in
Right?
First, a person
is is able to to free a slave. If
he's unable, then he is obligated to
fast two consecutive months. If he is
unable, then and only then would he feed
60 poor people.
And this is never to be skipped by
anyone, no matter how wealthy a person
is, no matter how able a person is. It
has to be in that order.
It's mentioned in the books of Usul
al-Fiqh
that once a very wealthy sultan
you know,
committed this sin here.
And so he asked
one of
his fuqaha, one of his
close scholars and advisers.
And this scholar said for him to fast
two consecutive months.
What did he skip?
Freeing the slave.
Why did he skip it? This is a sultan, of
course he can free a slave, he can free
a hundred slaves. Why did he skip it?
His reasoning was
because
if he frees a slave, that's too easy.
He's going to get off too easy.
And for him to really learn his lesson,
he needs to fast two consecutive months.
The scholars
The scholars all have consent have
reached consensus after him that that
fatwa was wrong.
Why?
Because sure
maybe this sultan will be benefited by
learning his lesson
by fasting 60 consecutive days.
But what happened to the slave that
could have been freed?
Right? So we don't skip around and
cherry-pick from the
from the
laws of our prophet
It is in that order. The benefits of the
reasons why Allah commands what he
commands are very multifaceted.
It's not just from one angle. And the
human being could never
take into consideration all of those
angles.
And so for this reason, we judge by the
book of Allah by the Sunnah of the
prophet
and we find usefulness in that.
And so
he asked him these three questions.
The man said, "No, he doesn't have the
ability to do any of these three
things."
So the prophet
just sat there. I mean, what else are we
going to say? There's nothing left to
say.
And so the scholars understood from this
that if a person were in this situation
then there's nothing upon him to do
until one of these three things makes
itself available to him.
As soon as one of these three things
becomes accessible to him, he is
obligated to do them
in the same order.
So he's poor
and he's unable to fast.
Let's say
after 10 years
he becomes he's somebody who who is able
to own a slave, then immediately he is
to emancipate a slave as a kaffarah. It
doesn't go away. It only is
it is only suspended
as long as his circumstances are the
same. But once his circumstances change
he is still obligated to do it.
He said
[Silence]
So as we were sitting there in the same
gathering
the prophet
was brought a basket
a type of basket full of dates. In
other wordings of this narration, the
dates were described as
they were still
fresh
ripe, they were not dried and they were
still on their stems. So it was a lot of
dates, right?
He said, "Where is the man that was just
asking, inquiring?" He said, "I am
here."
He said, "Me, I'm right here."
He said, "Take this and give it in
charity. So this here would count
towards the 60 poor people to feed. It
may not be able to feed all 60, but if
it fed three, four, five, 10 of them,
then it counts towards that.
Right?
So the man still has something up his
sleeve. We're not done yet.
[Silence]
He said, "Take this and give it in
charity." He said, "Give it to someone
more poor than me?
I swear by Allah, there is no
household
in Medina
more poor than my household."
[Silence]
He
said, "Should I feed it to someone more
poor than me? I swear by Allah that
there is not in Medina a household more
poor than my household."
And so the prophet
smiled until his teeth showed.
And he said, "Feed it to your family
then."
You know, imagine this narration. A man
comes
and says "I am burned, I'm finished, I'm
hopeless." And leaves with food.
Imagine that. This really captures
the prophet's
message.
If we were to say, "Give us an image of
what he was sent with."
We have sent you
not but as a mercy to all of creation.
If we were to say, "What image, what
story really captures all of that?" It
would be this story. A man comes saying,
"I am finished, I'm hopeless." And
leaves with food for his family.
Subhan Allah.
And so this narration is the evidence
that the author cites.
[Silence]
And another wording of this narration in
Sunan Abu Dawud, Abu Hurayrah narrates
that this man came to the prophet
having had broken his fast in Ramadan.
He's summarizing.
He says,
"And so the prophet
was brought a basket in it containing
tamr."
And then he tells us the amount of
dates. The amount was roughly 15 sa'.
15 sa'.
a sa'
is
a handful this.
You put your hands together.
You fill it with dates.
And these are the little dates that are
still
soft.
You put these together this, 15 of
those.
So how much is that?
I don't know, maybe couple couple
pounds.
Three, four pounds, something that.
I'm not I'm not sure of the exact math,
but that helps you to kind of
capture that. He says
And so the prophet
said to him, "Take this, eat it along
with your household and fast one day and
seek forgiveness
from Allah. What is the one day for?
Huh?
Qada.
The one day is for the one day that he
broke his fast.
But does this mean that he is completely
out of the woods for the rest of time?
No. Only if his circumstances never
change.
However, if any of his circumstances
change to where he is able to free a
slave or to fast 60 consecutive days or
to feed 60 poor people, it would still
be obligatory upon him. And we also
understand from this narration that if
he's able to feed some poor people
some of the 60, then he would
feed some of those 60. Even if it took
him 10 years to feed those 60 poor
people over time, then that would be
correct. But it doesn't work that way
for fasting. For the fasting, it has to
be consecutive.
For the fasting, it has to be
consecutive. But he commanded him to
make up the day that he missed. So, this
is
for
intercourse. Now, intercourse has a bare
minimum.
It's been quantified by the prophet
salallahu alayhi wasallam. He said
salallahu alayhi wasallam itha qa'ada
bayna shu'abiha arba'a
[Arabic recitation]
aqallahu
wuluj
al-hashafa.
Alladhi hu
ra'su al-dhakar.
Hadha aqallu al-jima'.
And so
even intercourse has been quantified.
Now, what about other things a wet
dream?
A wet dream will not affect a person's
fasting because it's involuntary. But
what about
you know,
a person gratifies himself,
right? Until he climaxes or she.
This will break a person's fast and they
must make that day up
according to the vast majority of the
scholars.
And there's a very long debate with
respect to this, but
the four madhahib and the vast majority
of the scholars, including the madhhab
of ahl al-hadith, is that this will
break a person's fast and that the
person must make this day up and that it
is prohibited and is one of the things
that breaks a person's fast. The author
didn't mention this.
And the reason the author didn't mention
this is because the author doesn't hold
that opinion.
The author holds the opinion of Ibn Hazm
al-Dhahiri and Dawud al-Dhahiri, which
is anna
al-istimna'
[Arabic recitation]
nadhar.
kulli hal
tomorrow, inshallah, we will go into the
preferred things to do
for the person who is fasting. As'alu
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala bi-mannihi wa
karamihi wa judih an yufaqqihana fi
[Arabic recitation]
alla yaj'alana mashghulina 'an wahyihi
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala an yuriyana
al-haqqa haqqan wa an yarzuqana
ittiba'ahu wa an yuriyana al-batila
batilan wa an yarzuqana ijtanabah.
Wallahu a'lamu salallahu wasallam 'ala
[Arabic recitation]
Maybe at the end we'll have a
question and answer or something. What
do you think? If you guys have questions
as we're talking, just, you know, ask as
we go along. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
fast for 60 days?
Huh? How can someone make the judgment
that they're unable to fast for 60 days?
if a person has health problems or if
a person works a very strenuous job that
they can't change or if a person, you
know, a person knows himself. It's a
very difficult thing to do. It's not
easy.
Right?
You can't.